I wake up at the crack of dawn to start
working and here's why you don't have to
in my opinion the most important thing
for an entrepreneur is to create space
so they can do deeper work so they can
build things so they can do long project
work that's going to provide significant
value to their employees or their
customers I can't normally do that in
the middle of the day when I'm getting
pinged and interrupted a lot of people
like to romanticize burning the midnight
oil or waking up at the crack of dawn
and the answer is it's neither of those
things it's just whatever works for you
and some people work really well late at
night when they're uninterrupted and
some people work really well in the
morning I'm a morning person but I think
the bigger takeaway is that you just
have to have time that you can push the
big rocks forward and not listen to
anyone who tells you that it's a certain
hour of day or whatever just do what
works for you